Carrusel de las artes
María Carolina piña
[Música]
un gusto saludarles desde París tengo el
agrado de presentarles nuestro programa
Carrusel de las artes desde el Palé
gallera de París el museo de la moda de
la capital la francesa que acoge sus
alas en este momento una exposición
magnífica en torno a Frida Kahlo Frida
Kahlo Más allá de las apariencias una
exposición que intenta explorar como
Frida Kahlo construyó su imagen y como
otros creadores posteriores a ellas se
inspiraron en su figura Y tenemos el
agrado de estar en compañía de dos
mujeres de las responsables dos de las
responsables de esta exposición
Circe en destroza la curadora mexicana
de la muestra y miren arsayos la
directora del palegalidad Muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros gracias
Y cuéntenos son muchos objetos que están
en esta exposición que han una parte ha
venido desde México cuéntenos que
descubrimos de Frida Kahlo que no
sepamos y que no hayamos visto hasta
ahora bueno esta exposición presenta
como ella construye su imagen a través
de de su de su guardarropa y su arte
digamos con las lecturas de la
discapacidad la etnicidad e inferencia
mexicana sus convicciones políticas y su
identidad de género entonces que
descubrimos en esta exposición a la
Frida íntima descubrimos al artista pero
también a la mujer y ahora son ex
objetos unos 200 objetos que vienen de
su casa de la casa azul de Coyoacán que
han salido por primera vez de México
estos objetos salieron por primera vez
de la casa azul en el 2018 en una
exposición que hicimos en una revisión
que se hizo en el Victoria en Londres y
después yo quería llevar la exposición a
los lugares en donde Frida vivió o pasó
tiempo que eran Nueva York San Francisco
y París París es una sede muy importante
porque es una de las sedes que reconoció
a Frida como un artista femenina en la
época y es un punto de transición muy
importante para ella entre su primera
exposición individual en Nueva York y
luego en Paraíso entonces París y Nueva
York se convierten en las dos ciudades
que la reconocen internacionalmente
cuando ella estaba viva y ahora en esta
exposición en París podemos ver los
vestidos de Frida Kahlo los objetos
collares aretes todo lo que ella utilizó
para crear esa imagen colorida
Revolucionaria incluso sí Exacto para
nosotros Bueno ella siempre ha estado
muy adelantada su tiempo o sea de hecho
ella es relevante hoy porque ella estaba
lidiando con o revisando
los temas de diversidad que que hoy
están en tanto apogeo en desde los años
veintes y también los temas que pintaba
se pintaba con los corsets descubiertos
hablaba de de sus diferencias
corporales de sus experiencias femeninas
del cuerpo humano o de su experiencia
femenina a través de de abortos de se
pinta sus autorretratos portando sus sus
vestidos de tehuana Entonces esta
exposición reúne por primera vez
todos sus objetos personales Sí pero
también
sus retratos y sus fotografías que nos
dan una lectura más rica porque muestran
como todos estos materiales contribuían
a este proceso creativo de de lo que es
hoy Frida Kahlo miren arzallus estamos
en el museo de la moda a Qué mirada
tiene usted de estas piezas que
contenido desde México son vestidos
además que vienen de la cultura mexicana
que fría utilizaba que combinaba a su
manera muy particular que podemos
descubrir de esa apariencia de esa moda
a la Frida Kahlo que se presenta aquí en
París Bueno yo creo que una de las
razones por las que el Palé ya llega
aquí y pensamos que era muy importante
sobre todo muy relevante hacer esta
exposición en nuestro museo en París era
bueno por todo lo que lo que ha dicho
hasta ahora hacerte es decir que en
tanto que museo de moda nos interesan
todos aquellos relatos aquellos
proyectos aquellos aquellas exposiciones
que pongan en el centro en los que el
vestido sea su eje principal y a través
de los que podamos contar la importancia
del vestido para nuestra propia
identidad para construirnos para
expresarnos para mostrarnos Hasta qué
punto es central en nuestra vida Frida
Kahlo ilustra mejor que nadie iba a
decir porque hay una tal concentración
de cuestiones a través de Frida que
podemos abordar a través del caso
concreto de Frida que nos parece
absolutamente fundamental otros museos
internacionales no han querido quizá
profundizar en esta cuestión porque
quizás les parecía menor Pero bueno
nosotros siendo un museo dedicado a la
moda pues nos ha parecido que no era
ningún caso menor sino muy importante
Hasta qué punto ella inspira y sigue
inspirando a la creación de moda
contemporánea que lo hace de formas muy
diferentes hay una forma pues vamos a
decir que se queda en la estética no
está esta estética que transmite tanta
Pues eso tanto como dicen tantas
felicidad alegría felicidad como sobre
todo alegría de vivir no
que ahí es donde nos quedamos en esa
primera lectura estética no Y esas
flores esas Bueno pues que es que es
realmente una estética muy fuerte muy
inspiradora el papel que los corsés
tienen en como el corsé se convierte en
una segunda piel como se convierte casi
en una prenda y cómo se convierte
también en una obra de arte No pues hay
creadores por ejemplo que están
representados aquí porque hemos querido
Mostrar esta influencia también como por
ejemplo Alexander Mcqueen en el que
podemos ver Pues como dice decirte un
proceso creativo similar y una
interpretación del corsé es similar a lo
que a lo que hizo la propia Frida
Entonces es
infinita Frida Kahlo tenemos que
recordar que Frida Kahlo sufrió polio
muy pequeñita a los seis años y luego un
gran accidente que casi fue fatal que le
fracturó la columna vertebral en varios
lugares ella necesitaba usar corset o
aparatos ortopédicos y esos aparatos
ortopédicos los podemos ver aquí en la
posición de París incluso yesos Que ella
misma pintó y eso es algo muy emotivo de
ver Estos son las piezas realmente
muy conmovedoras para el mismo tiempo
representan este acto de
el día porque ella pintaba necesitaba
estos corsets como soporte médico pero
también los interviene los pinta
convirtiéndolos en en obras de arte como
nos explicaba miren Y de alguna forma
como blusas por ejemplo Porque si yo se
quería quitar su blusa y estar por su
casa pues ya estaba decorado el el yeso
Entonces fungía también como este
acercamiento también es muy muy
interesante es muy avanzar digamos y
ahora quedábamos de esos corsés de yeso
también vemos en esta exposición otros
corsés hechos por creadores posteriores
El corcel fue muy importante fue Frida
la que lo puso en la mesa de la moda
Bueno la verdad es que yo creo que hay
una determinada interpretación del corsé
que el que debemos a Frida no porque es
verdad que el corsé pues es ha
caracterizado la moda pues sobre todo
desde el siglo 17 vamos a decir en la
moda occidental desde el siglo XVII Y
eso pues se ha convertido a lo largo de
la historia Pues en una continua vamos a
decir fuente de inspiración de
reinterpretación además ha tenido muchas
significaciones diferentes ya sea se
identifica con la sensualidad con el
erotismo pero también se identifica
desde la perspectiva feminista como algo
que oprime no como algo que nos ha
oprimido durante durante muchos años
pero yo creo que lo que lo que Frida
hace con estos corsés esa interpretación
que Frida hace esa relación que ella
tiene con sus corsés que es lo que
estaba hablando desde ahora esa esa
vamos a decir porque a la vez es un es
un objeto es decir que la constriñe
porque le Recuerda la fragilidad de su
cuerpo y su dolor a la vez Es una
herramienta fundamental para que ella
pueda soportar su cuerpo pero a la vez
como dice decirte vamos a decir se
expresa lo convierte Por una parte en un
accesorio en una prenda porque a veces
va sin nada más que ese corséis Así nada
más que se cosese y además se convierte
casi en una obra de arte porque como
muchas veces decirte todo entre llegar
es una creación porque ella utiliza todo
lo que tiene todo su entorno todos los
objetos que tienen a su disposición para
expresarse entonces Ella misma se crea a
sí misma ella misma es forma parte de su
obra no está Mire con una palabra sobre
esta sala en la que nos encontramos que
es la segunda parte de la exposición
dedicada a esos creadores del siglo 20
que se inspiraron en Frida Kahlo hay
obras de las casas dior Chanel givenchy
Cómo construyó usted de esta esta
pequeña muestra por supuesto hay por
ejemplo dos colecciones homenaje es
decir son estas ocasiones en las que los
creadores ellos mismos Ahí vamos a decir
el eje es Frida Kahlo el eje de toda su
exposición y han querido rendir homenaje
a esta mujer que les ha inspirado para
crear una colección es el caso de la
colección de primavera verano de 1998 de
San Paul gauche en más recientemente
también ha creado una colección homenaje
es muy interesante ver las dos porque
son dos maneras muy diferentes de
interpretar o de inspirarse en Frida
Kahlo Pero en fin caemos sobre las
mismas cuestiones su cuerpo su relación
con su cuerpo su fuerza
su Estilo la construcción de su imagen
todo eso sigue inspirando y luego por
ejemplo pues no sé tenemos otras
creaciones en las que Bueno pues abunda
más los bordados las flores el color las
formas de sus blusas bueno por ejemplo
Tenemos aquí la colección de ardem que
también es reciente del que él después
de un viaje a México quedó completamente
fascinado por la historia de tinamodotti
de Frida Kahlo y creo esta maravillosa
colección quiero decir que son muchas
las maneras y muy diferentes en las que
los creadores han sentido inspirados por
Frida a veces es más evidente a veces es
algo que ellos mismos han querido
declarar no y otras veces Bueno pues son
son interpretaciones también que
nosotros hemos hecho pero bueno que
todos los creadores cuando porque
obviamente hemos pedido muchos préstamos
a diferentes casas de moda y ellos
mismos han estado encantados de
prestarnos estas piezas por lo que creo
que se sienten muy cómodos con esta
interpretación que nosotros hacemos las
interpretaciones es aquella
está relacionada a la memoria que acá lo
ha dejado en estos diseñadores y ellos
toman de ella lo que les inspira a ellos
no y hemos también escogido
o intentado escoger aquellos diseñadores
que se inspiraron en los temas que
Nosotros también estamos
tratando como como la parte andrógina la
parte del cuerpo de la fragilidad del
cuerpo esta colección de Jean Paul
gaultier que que pues él en realidad de
mezcla un poco todos los temas y Y sí y
la y la parte de de McQueen que que hace
un paralelo de los corsets con ese
directo los corsets abajo de Frida esto
más como una producción una un
acercamiento creativo de esto es una
comparación que hacemos de cómo el
acercamiento creativo de la anatomía del
cuerpo humano Frida Kahlo entonces sigue
siendo una inspiración Incluso en El
Siglo 21 para todos los creadores
Muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros la curadora mexicana Circe en
stroza y miren arzalos la directora del
palet Galera de París Muchísimas gracias
a todos ustedes por haber estado con
nosotros en este Carrusel de las artes y
hasta la próxima
[Música]